[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining me thank you for
having me on your show
how you doing i'm doing very well how
are you
good well you're an expert on happiness
so if you weren't doing too well i'd be
a little worried
uh for all of our sake let's just dive
into it
what is happiness you know so let me
start with that you know
being a happiness uh uh
expert doesn't exempt one from uh from
being unhappy at times okay thank god
you know what one of the um one of the
barriers to happiness actually
is um the expectation that one can be
uh happy without experiencing painful
emotions but these are you know
part of life and certainly during these
difficult times
they're a part of any life so today i'm
doing well three days ago
not well at all okay well so tal you you
mean you taught
at two of the most popular classes at
harvard you're a global speaker around
the world on the subject of happiness
consulting you know the top companies in
the world on this thing
what is it about happiness that entices
people and why is it a field that needs
to be studied the way that that you
approached it
so the reason why people are interested
in it i mean there are various one is
that it's in our nature to pursue
happiness
you know uh aristotle talked about it
confucius talked about how our
highest end the goal to which all other
ends lead
uh is happy this is that's why
it's our nature to do that sorry maslow
as well abraham maslow with the pyramid
at the end it's self-fulfillment and
getting to that
arena factualization exactly and some
people call it happiness some people
talk more about a sense of meaning and
purpose but
essentially we're looking for the good
life whatever that good life is
and here comes the importance of
studying it because there are
a lot of misunderstandings about what
happiness is for example when people
expect
that happiness is is a constant high
that
actually limits their ability to
experience happiness when people think
that happiness is just about
emotions that's a problem because
happiness is also about a sense of
meaning and purpose
happiness is also about cultivating the
mind body
connection and and so on and the reason
why it's important for it to become a
field of study
is because today we have or over the
years we have a lot of self-help work
new age work more recently that tell us
okay here are the three
things you need to do to be happy you
know the
one secret of the good life these things
unfortunately don't exist no it takes
work and like um
success in any field um
success quote importing being happy i he
becoming happier
also takes work and takes understanding
of the antecedents of what it takes to
be happy
right so so what is i mean you know
there is a proliferation of all these
self-help books and videos and speakers
that are
you know they bring the promise of if
you listen if you listen and you do
these three steps you'll be happy
so what in your mind constitutes a
process or a path
to be to feeling more self-fulfilled and
now i'm asking just for myself because i
want to become that way
yeah so what are the things that we can
do to become happier well
there are various things the first thing
and accept
embrace all emotions regardless of what
they are rather when we fight when we
reject painful emotions they intensify
so accept embrace in other words the the
foundation
um of happiness is actually allowing in
unhappiness uh second you know i
mentioned the mind body connection
physical exercise there's a lot of
research showing that regular physical
exercise has the same effect
on our psychological well-being is our
most powerful powerful psychiatric
medication
wow so exercising regularly is uh is key
you know whether we do it at home
whether we do it out outdoors
um move it move it so you you do it
right you swim you do yoga
you do you go you do yoga you run you're
a very active person yourself
yes i i i am and you know you talk about
yoga yoga there's another element here
of mindfulness
yeah being present uh whether it's
through meditation whether it's through
a
yoga practice whether it's listening to
music or engaging in a conversation and
really being present
to the the person that has numerous
benefits psychological
and physiological relationships
number one predictor of happiness is
quality time we spend with people we
care about
and who care about us now ideally we
want to do it face to face
right uh three three dimension not
virtually
but if we have no choice then virtual is
a lot a lot better
than nothing at all by the way regarding
virtually so you know this is very
relevant to our times and i'd love to
shift the conversation soon to what what
does it mean to
to to contain these emotions we're
feeling right now
is there any research or any thought
behind the
connections we're building virtually
versus in person
especially regarding to the emotional
effect that it has on us
yeah look i ideally we want to have
those uh
face-to-face interactions where we're
sitting in the same room and can uh
um you know literally or metaphorically
feel each right
and having said that
um in these times you know when that is
not an
option and when there's a social
distancing
um we need to do what we can and what we
can today
is interacting uh online and then
and that's okay you know you can form uh
real relationships
virtually you know it's interesting
there's research
on introverts and extroverts and
interestingly introverts have a much
higher likelihood of forming intimate
relationships
that start online and the reason is
because it's sort of you know it's
easier it's an
icebreaker you have more of a barrier or
protection yeah
um but again but but but virtual is no
substitute for
uh for the real thing right you know
sometimes i look back and i and i listen
to my grandparents stories back from the
haganah
and the formation of israel and you know
friends who were who were lived in the
kibbutz
and one of the common things that
they're telling me is you know back then
it was simpler times we would go on the
tractor and we would just knock on each
other's door to
talk and we didn't have all the stress
that we have today and we were happier
so in your mind you've been studying
this for so long
what do you see you know as civilization
as a whole
are we moving to a less happy place as a
result
of all of this sort of artificial
communication
or are we able to overcome that and
achieve similar levels of happiness that
you know my grandparents experienced
no it's it's very clear that uh our
um the technology leading to us being
away from one another is leading to less
happiness
you know you even look at the national
levels of happiness the happiest
countries in the world
are not the ones you would expect
meaning it's not the us it's not the uk
it's not germany it's not singapore or
korea
the happiest countries in the world are
um some of the scandinavian countries
israel is among the happiest countries
in the world why is that
colombia is among the happiest countries
in the world and the question is why
these countries
and and not the wealthiest countries in
the world right well the one
common element and among these countries
is that
there is social support there the
relationships
friendships family relationships are a
priority
you know yes of course you you need the
basic uh
basic needs have to be met for happiness
you know so the poorest countries in the
world are not the happiest countries in
the world
and also countries where there is war
going on you know war zones obviously
they're not happy so you need
you know you were talking about maslow
the basic fundamentals shelter food
safety security
but after that is fulfilled the next
essential element for happiness is the
relate
are the relationships the um the the
social support
and in our culture today it's it's
really being eroded
in in in so many parts of the world by
the way
also in the happiest countries in the
world so i did research uh
last year in latin america perhaps the
happiest region
in the world not so for the new
generation because the new generation
don't meet as often face to face as
their parents
right so they're sort of in an
in-between phase where they're trying to
adopt
these new world technologies but there's
that's that's very very interesting
i would love to hear a little bit about
this these classes that you teach at
harvard and
what is it like you know give me your
two cents on teaching some of the most
popular classes at one of the most
prestigious universities in the world
you know from more of the lecturer's
perspective you know you're influencing
hundreds of
of brilliant students at a time why are
people so excited about these classes
that
usually i'm guessing are not in line
with the major that they're choosing
yeah you know so um so first of all
today i'm no longer at harvard today i'm
teaching at columbia
um but the reason why students whether
it colombia or
or at harvard are attracted to a class
of on happiness
is because ultimately that's what we all
want so whether we go into investment
banking or whether we go into
into teaching or or medicine or
not for profit it doesn't matter what we
what we all want
is more happiness what we all want is
more happiness for people we
care about um so this is a highly
practical class yes i teach
theory i talk about you know all the
research in the field you know this is
not a self-help seminar yeah
and at the same time at the same time
um everything is applied so
when i teach i have a few criteria one
it has to be based on rigorous research
two it has to be relevant
to the students lives meaning it's
something that they can take apply
whether it's today or
five years hence when they have a you
know when they get married
right and the third thing there are
always
things that um that i apply in my
life so i never teach things that i
don't try out and don't use
it doesn't mean that i've mastered these
things but it's things that are
that are part of my life uh so it's with
these three
criteria that um has has attracted
and many students because i can speak
about it firsthand
because it's relevant to their lives and
because they know that it's based on
science
yeah and you know with the the other
epidemic that's happening in the us with
mental health you know i see it at
stanford this
you know rigorous um trial and error by
the institution to try and minimize the
mental health issues that we have on
campus because you know it is very
competitive and
the world is moving at a faster and
faster pace we feel it
this you know the day you walk into
campus so automatically they ask you
what's your internship for the summer
and you're like whoa whoa whoa
i just stepped in here and and it's so
it's really interesting and and you know
the second you talked about
how you experience these things
firsthand i can't help but go back you
know to elementary school and i remember
have that i had this
physical education teacher who would
come in smelling of cigarettes and
had a big beer belly and he would tell
me to run and
kept thinking to myself what are you
telling me to run
that's fascinating so you know i want to
shift this a little bit
yeah i want to know about myself because
you know in five years i see myself as a
ceo of a nice company
hopefully both doing good for the world
and and making
a good amount of money for the business
what do i have to do
as a ceo to bring better culture
to my employees bring better happiness
and be happier myself
so i would start with the end first you
begin with yourself you know gandhi said
be the change you want to see in the
world
and if you can introduce some of these
practices that
that i talked about or we'll talk about
then um
by extension they're contagious and
they're they're more likely to find
their way into the lives of your
employees
and so what can you do again um lead a
a healthy life and a healthy life means
a life
that has stress because stress is not
bad for us
and at the same time also has recovery
in it so um you know i think of uh
of the of the the metaphor of a racing
car you know a ceo or a manager
you know wants to function at a very
high level like a racing car but even a
racing car needs pit stops
if we don't have those pit stops right
that's going to burn out uh
when burnout happens so you as well as
your employees need
to yeah work hard and also know how to
play hard or recover hard
um so that's one of the second thing
more and more
organizations are realizing the
importance of
psychological safety psychological
safety is a concept introduced uh by uh
amy edmonds and warren bennis
um where um it's about
the the feeling that it's okay to take
risks that the feeling is that it's okay
to fail
that it's uh okay to ask questions
um and having this psychological safety
in your organization and it's basically
up to you
as the manager to to make sure that it's
there
that leads to good things happening
whether good things
psychologically emotionally and also
good things in terms of
innovation and creativity as well as
productivity
no that makes a lot of sense and you
know most interestingly
most interestingly we're in these crazy
times of corona that are you know
unprecedented and people did not expect
or prepare for them
so how do what is it like from your take
as you're watching this whole thing
unfold
what does it mean to you know society
norms and how is that going to affect
you know overall emotional levels that
we experience
yeah so you know what what's happening
right now is that we're experiencing
more emotions more complex emotions and
more
intense emotions um
so for instance when people experience
fear um
fear levels have skyrocketed are
skyrocketing there is a lot more anxiety
whether it's for your health for your
parents health
for the you know future of the world uh
in terms of health in terms of the
economy as well there's a lot of anxiety
uh going around which is extreme at the
same time there's also a great deal more
gratitude
right now you know more and more people
um are experience
experiencing gratitude for being okay
the thing though is that very often with
gratitude comes also guilt
you know guilt over you know how can i
be grateful not now how can i be
happy now when um
[Music]
you know when there are so many people
who are suffering and just
there so it's a much more complex set of
emotion and again the key is to
um accept embrace whatever
emotion uh comes up now what's gonna
happen with
with what we're going through for the
future it depends on us you know there
is real potential here because i think
many people are learning very important
lessons
you know whether it's the lessons of
appreciation whether it's the lesson
of um spending more time with loved ones
whether it's the lesson of um being more
attentive and taking better care of
mother earth
or whatever it is there are many
important lessons that we're deriving
the question is
are these lessons going to going to last
or are we going to forget and revert
right back to where we were before
a minute after this is over right is
there enough
research about this around the world i
mean is this a big enough topic that
people are giving enough weight to
because you know as
far as i'm concerning happiness and and
understanding what enables people to
become happier and live more fulfilled
lives
it seems that out of my out of the 24
hours of my day
i don't spend nearly enough pondering
that question and taking active steps
to improve my happiness and when i look
at you know some of the most successful
people around me
i don't think they're doing enough
either so
is there enough or what needs to happen
so that we will reach
a position where we're putting enough
effort yeah
so so the key here is um i don't think
that everyone should become a happiness
scholar
or that people should become you know
obsessed with becoming happier that's
actually
not healthy right what is healthy is
adopting
a a handful of practices
and then um applying them doing them
consistently
you know so for instance if you're a
thing you you know you want to do a
do meditation by all means go take a
meditation class online
you know perfectly perfectly good and
then start meditating for five minutes a
day
that will have a much more powerful
impact than you know if you go on a you
know
a 10-day retreat now and then do nothing
afterwards
so small changes consistent over time
um second you know physical exercise
start exercising it doesn't you don't
have to
train to be to be an iron man right but
uh three times a week 30 minutes of
aerobic exercise that could be walking
or it could be uh
you know high-intensity interval
training or whatever it is doing it
regularly that can make a big difference
so consistency that's
that's a big part of it consistency it's
the biggest part of it
you know consistency and over time much
more important than those
big changes radical transformations that
many people are looking for
first of all it usually doesn't it
doesn't last yeah um
and second it's also very difficult to
to commit to those and therefore we put
them off whereas small changes
are more palpable and that they're more
accessible
right and i think a lot of people with
with high motivation levels and i
consider myself included it's very
difficult
to say okay i'm gonna start let's say
meditation and i'm gonna do it for five
minutes a day no i'll jump to 30 minutes
a day
because because if i'm gonna do
something i'll do it all the way
and and it has negative effects i
experienced this firsthand there was a
marathon in a lot
two years ago and i used to run you know
in high school and in middle school
but i wasn't in shape and i signed up
for the marathon
because i don't know i wanted to
challenge myself i ended up finishing it
successfully but i injured myself in the
process and that was a very big life
lesson for me
of building incremental progress and i
thought i would be happy finishing the
marathon
and while i was satisfied on one hand i
couldn't help but feel that i
missed something by not going through
the process of achieving that milestone
and i actually started meditating every
day starting at five minutes
building it up and and it completely
transformed my emotional levels i think
and so i definitely agree tal before we
finish
i want to ask you the last question and
that is what are three words that you
think best describe you
and i'm especially curious to hear your
answer on this
um so the first word is um
family man i know
it's two words i lied but i'll take it
i'll take it as one
there's one thank you and the second
word is uh
student the third word is
realistic family man student realistic
i love it tal thank you so so much for
the inspiration for the time
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
the same to you
and your family take care